foreign
[Music]
my son now and I just fell in love I
mean I didn't I didn't see autism I see
the individual he has a difficulties um
on his daily life I mean he's totally
dependent because he has no sense of
dangers he will cross the street and
will put himself in a dangerous
situation and he's known verbal so he
cannot say anything about
um I mean what how is his feeling things
like that that creates some frustrations
because you cannot express he's a big
motivation now the translational side I
really want to to make sure my science
can can help him and others like him
um to kind of cope with with autism in
daily life and become independent right
um but on the other side I I don't want
to lose him and my interactions with him
otherwise I would be working like 24
hours
um and then just doing that but I I want
to enjoy his life and uh and that comes
a challenge I mean how how you do the
same things that would do with uh um we
call neurotypical or normal person but
to be honest I mean makes life
unpredictable and I like it I've been
enjoying the process right
um what I would say to other parents or
their families is not let the condition
takes over your life
um but embrace it I mean that that's it
I mean better days will come I'm highly
optimistic about that
um but until that I mean trying to make
the best of your life any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic
[Music]
Professor Allison Moultrie welcome to
the into the impossible Studios thanks
Brian long do yes it has been overdue I
don't often get to chat with someone
who's literally a rock star and has a
grant to prove it uh you are a professor
here a colleague friend of of ours here
at the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination you've been involved for
quite some time you're a rocket
scientist you're a brain surgeon you do
all these things people say you know
they can't tell the difference between
which is more interesting or difficult
but you do them both so that's really
cool we're going to talk about Rockets
we're going to talk about brains we're
going to talk about everything but first
I want to give a quick background on who
you are where you came from your kind of
your origin story so you're from Brazil
originally as my sister-in-law is and uh
I wanted to kind of uh take Trace your
path from from South America all the way
up to here and to become the leader that
you are among many many other projects
but the ones we're going to be speaking
about today involve setting bits of
brains into space and actually just
studying them here on Earth so take it
away else all right yeah so I um I'm
originally from Sao Paulo Brazil
um my family is a middle class family
oranges from Italy
um so I think we are third generation of
Italians in in Sao Paulo in Brazil and I
was always like a scientist I didn't
know exactly what kind of scientist but
I was always very curious very into
natures and exploring everything
um and that that drove me to do uh
biology to study biology
um so that was
um uh when I joined the University of
Campinas which is uh in the countryside
of Sao Paulo um for my undergrad studies
and after that I I moved straight
directly to a PhD program
um at the University of Sao Paulo this
was uh on on DNA repair learning about
the DNA metabolism cells at that stage I
was already into
um
genetics trying to understand human
genetics so my PhD was human genetics
and potential like gene therapy ways to
to interact with the genome and that was
um back in 2001 so in 2002 I moved to uh
the Salk Institute to work with Rusty
gauge a good friend a good Mentor and I
learned more about stem cells in
neuroscience and in 2008 2009 that's
when I got my first faculty position
here in us and I decided to to stay and
I've been here I mean for several years
now and you're in both Pediatrics and
you're also in cellular molecular
medicine cellular and that's a kind of a
unique department or division that most
universities don't have so Pediatrics
people you know should know more or less
they were once you know seen by such
Physicians but what is a cellular and
molecular Medical Department what is
that about yeah I know that that's a
great question and this is a very unique
to use SCD we have within the school of
meds in a very deep fundamental uh
Department that studies the molecular
level what happens inside the cells to I
mean the cell structures itself
um and and it's a it's a small
Department it's a group of people really
interesting on
um basic stuff um so there is no
potential application of course I mean
we all diverge and and it starts working
on on diseases and conditions like that
but uh most of these guys are really
into how the cell works and so is it
helpful that you know in the future
we'll be able to actually maybe perhaps
avoid certain invasive medical
procedures by actually engineering
molecules and cells to do the bidding
for us yeah I think that's um I mean I
don't think it's no longer science
fiction I think this is uh on the
pipeline uh it's just that the tools
when we start are not the best ones I
mean I think you you can relate to that
so you build something that seems to be
working you have a proof of concept and
then it takes several years to to make
that
um uh something that will go into
clinics that people would use every day
say that the MDS the medical doctors
will understand
um so we are in this process with lots
of these tools from gene therapy from
genome editing
um from the stem cells from predicting
how tissue cells Works um but I think we
are in the right pref
so what are organoins we hear about
these um these these objects it sounds
like an organ sounds like an Android uh
are they uh are they you know sort of
more towards the organ or more towards
the Android yeah so the the organoid is
really um I mean from the war this is a
small version of the tissue right I mean
you have brain organoid you have lung
organoids you have pancreas organ white
so it's a it's a small miniaturized
version of the tissue
um it gives you the impression that you
you really have like an entire tissue
it's just like a small version but
that's not the case usually we have
pieces of tattoos that are not
um complete but good enough to serve as
a model
um and there are limitations I mean you
don't have all the cells the size is
different this organ noise are not
vascularized and that's one of the main
limitations why they don't grow even
bigger
um so but up even with those limitations
there is useful because they are
mimicking the organ in a
three-dimensional version which is
something that we know it it works but
back in the lab it's hard to control
things in 3D so we most of the lab or I
would say like for the past 100 years
people are looking into cells in a
two-dimension configuration and and more
recently we are applying it becomes more
um routine to use three-dimensional
organized to study
um how the tissue Works how how does an
organoid differ from a stem cell or are
they related to each other they are
related yeah the organoids are most of
the time I mean coming from Human
protipotent stem cells and purely potent
stem cells are those stem cells that can
make any type of tissue in the body so
these are your primordial embryonic stem
cells back into the blastocyst inside
the uterus that's that's dispersed cells
that start to differentiate specialize
in the different tissues in the embryo
so scientists I mean learn how to
isolate this peripotent stem cells
either from the embryo or more recently
from live people and and created these
pretty potent stem cells that can be
then induced to become the different
cell types or different tissues that you
want and most of this knowledge is um
has been accumulated over the years with
the most fundamental basis in embryology
especially Mouse embryology and we try
to apply for it to humans sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't so there is a
little bit of a trial and narrow until
you figure out exactly what is the
formula the recipe to create a brain
organoid and not a pancreas organoid so
over the time we're learning how to do
this better and better becoming more
reproducible
um and and reliable are there you know
more or fewer kind of ethical
considerations when it comes to using
organoids as opposed to stem cells I
remember when the Stanford in the
Consortium and the stem cell initiative
which you're a big part of or a big part
about it we'll talk more about that in a
bit but when that first came about there
were you know a lot of controversy
within and without of the State of
California are there as I say more or or
less kind of concerns ethically speaking
on the practice of extraction and and
engineering and utilization of organoids
as opposed to stem cells right yeah so
the uh the stem cell field is always
with some kind of a controversial right
I mean and I think the biggest
controversial that we're probably
alluding to is the use of human
embryonics themselves because to to use
those cells requires the destruction of
the embryo and some religious peoples
are against about that so when I arrive
in U.S that was a 2001-2002 that was
under the Bush Administration who
prohibited to use embryonic stem cells
with federal grants so people have to
use like private funds to work with
these cells but fortunately what happens
in 2007-2008 was someone called Shina
yamanaka colleague of mine was able to
show that you can take a piece of your
semantic cells these are cells that are
available not your gem line cells and
reprogram these cells back to this
pluripotent state so by doing that you
avoid um the use of embryonic stem cells
so that's no longer an issue because we
can use these induced pluripotent stem
cells now but also the good news is that
by doing that by reprogram cells from a
specific individual I capture the Genome
of that individual for example if I now
take like a piece of your skin go back
reprogram into this pretty potent stand
State I can make a brain organoid for
new from Brian and that brain can write
contain your genetic information to show
how your brain were formed or was formed
during the embryonic a kind of a replay
your embryonic stages in the lab oh wow
we can replay my first kiss with my wife
quite attractive right honey
um so I have a brain here uh this one
was down no this one was not donated by
my graduate students so it has many
different components to it right so uh
you know the only connection I have with
the brain is that most people confuse
and conflate my name with the word brain
in fact you did and I'm saving and
printing out that email for posterity
the world's foremost expert called me
brain and I appreciate that so here's a
brain there's many different parts we
don't have to get into all of them I I
believe it's true though that you know
the frontal cortex which I think is this
side right right
um is sort of the cinequanon the most
interesting exciting part about what
differentiates you know both the size
and the capability of the human brain
from bonobos or something else
um what what part of the brain is being
replicated or or modeled by an organoid
or or is it just generic because it
seems just looking at there's gray
matter uh can you you know play around
with it and let me know where is it
actually coming from yeah no absolutely
yeah the uh your frontal cortex is
really the the reason for the
computational capacity the complexity
your emotions it all boils down to the
frontal cortex and that's why it's very
interesting uh for scientists and not to
understand not only to understand
evolution of the human brain which is
kind of cool
um but also several diseases have
problems in the cortex like autism
schizophrenia so all these conditions
psychiatric conditions have a problem
specific with the frontal cortex so
um I mean there's no no surprise that
this was one of the first reasons that
scientists decided to focus and we have
like good protocols to create
um the frontal cortex so there are other
regions as you pointed out I mean you
have like a nice um uh uh cerebellum
here which is also implicated in in
autism but also help you to coordinate
your your movements
um so that's is a structure that happens
a little bit late in life and and we
don't know exactly how it happens in in
humans or or what are the factors that
we need to recreate that perfectly so
the protocol to create like a cerebellar
organoid
um is lacking behind because we are we
are not all that focused on creating
that
um but there are other these three atom
is a its focus for um
neurons these are the center of dopamine
and it's a region that gets damage if
you have Parkinson you lose the
dopaminergic neurons inside your brain
so we are learning how to create this
dopaminergic neurons or or brain
organoid from these three atoms so we
could replace that for Parkinson so you
can see how these organoids can also be
useful for regenerative medicine
um down the road some of these clinical
trials are already like in the pipeline
and will be happening soon so uh big
picture question we've had on people
like sir Roger Penrose one of the
original guests on this podcast and uh
and he's been asked by me and many other
people is the brain a computer I'd love
to get your perspective on that we're
we're we're on the computational
spectrum is a computer relative to a
brain and what things do they have in
common uh from your perspective well I
mean uh from from the simple concept of
of a computer or some something that you
you add an input and and and gives you
like an output with some some process
information in that sense I would say
yes but I think the way the brain
computes is kind of quite unique and uh
we don't know that yet and by the way
that's one of the exciting projects that
I have here with um uh colleagues that
use SCD is to really understand how the
brain computes
um and if we do that then you can
imagine I mean all all the kind of a
processing that is happening in our
minds while we're here talking
um with a very low cost of energy and
and to do something with AI it would
take like way more energy and way more
computational power to to execute that
so how come the brain learns how to do
that with so low energy so this is one
of the questions that I'm fascinating
about to learn how the brain does how
the brain learns it's about 100 Watts uh
equivalent yeah Power yeah it's pretty
amazing and it's a squishy computer it's
a it's a wet computer right which I'm
going to take my iPhone into that
environment uh again because that'll you
know invoke Apple Care
um but the notion that you know there is
this ability for now we live in this era
where you know everybody's using GPT and
chat Bots and so forth but I always like
to remind people that you know the most
famous physicist in history you know
present company excluded was Albert
Einstein and Albert uh said the happiest
thought of his life was that an observer
in free fall would not experience a
gravitational field uh and that led him
along the way to the the what we call
the Einstein equivalence principle and
other things
point out you know to what extent could
a computer replicate the feeling of a
happiness to have oh it's my happiest
thought of my my uh you know my CPU is
it was really operating at maximum
efficiency
um and B how could it visualize the
sensation of free fall so I very curious
from your perspective to what extent can
a computer
ever potentially replicate what the
creative you know capability is of the
you know cerebellum or cerebrum of a
human being do you think it's possible
will we be replaced with AI AES like
Albert Einstein yeah I think uh I mean
from
and maybe I mean if we have if we ever
had like a computer that might process
information as the brain let's let's
suppose that that we have now I think it
will be able to articulate that as long
as you teach them what is the feeling of
Happiness right I mean you have to teach
a computer how to do that yeah but once
you do that I think it will be able to
learn and and and apply to different
conditions that are similar
um having like this sensation of uh
feeling or doing good
um based on other previous sensation
which is more or less how the brain does
as well right
um I had a friend in college I won't
give his name because he is a listener
out there how you doing out there I
won't say his name uh but he's uh his
father was an uh an orthodontist okay
and he had braces for 11 years and you
know it's kind of cruel that you know
his father basically was using him for
experimentation uh now I understand that
both the first you know organoid uh some
of the first organized or organized
material perhaps came from a father who
had a son with autism and I understand
your stepson also has autism so there's
a personal angle I wonder if you could
explore that what is it I mean I'm a
father of of of many children
um you know and and and I've been
involved with the Simon's Foundation who
supports a tremendous amount of autism
research for their Safari program uh
first of all what is it what is it like
um having a child uh with autism uh and
you know are there any tips we have a
lot of listeners who do have uh children
on different varieties of the neural
Divergence but in particular in autism
so I wonder could you you know kind of
uh share your experience as a father
yeah um and and of your son and then
we'll get into the scientific you know
experimentation that we'd love to do in
our rights right right I mean that let
me step back on this story first because
I was in studying autism way before him
um and uh the major motivation at the
time was really to understand um how the
human brain evolved if you look around
the other species I mean you don't
really see
they are trying to get to the moon right
I mean they're not doing anything like
that and there are no evidence that the
Neanderthals which would be like really
close to us we'll do the same thing even
though they have been on earthwork
longer than us but there is no evidence
that they were in that level of
sophistication
um in the debatable about all these
reasons but that was I was trying to
understand why what happens to the human
brain that make us so unique and that
led me to study autism because one of
the key components of being human is
your social ability the way that we talk
communicate interact with others and we
can do that in a high order of magnitude
compared to other primates who are
limited on that amount of connections
that they can make and deal in a daily
basis so we we can surpass the
chimpanzee um by three times I believe
um so and and then autism was uh a one
way where this system is not functioning
well because autistic interviews tend to
be more introspective and make less
social contact so I went to study autism
at the same time I mean there's a
another syndrome called William syndrome
and it's a deletion in chromosome 7 that
makes you hypersocial so in a way it's a
very simplistic way it's an opposite of
autism so these are people that are
attracted to new faces attracted to
strangers
um so I was dealing with those two
syndromes
um and and by studying them I mean you
you make discoveries and one of the
discoveries that we did was that um the
alterations that we see in the autistic
brains are not permanent which is was a
major dog in my neurosciences people
would think that alterations during
early development would stay there
forever and I think we have to revisit
that idea I think some of these
syndromes are reversible and um so we
made that Discovery using like stem
cells and and and then I went for talk
in Brazil and that's how I met my wife
and she was there as a mom with someone
with autism and um so that's uh that's
then then we met we started the
conversation and and then I met Yvonne
um my son now and I just fell in love I
mean I didn't I didn't see autism I see
the individual and it was quite severe I
mean he's uh
um he has um difficulties um on his
daily life I mean he's totally dependent
um I I joke but he's not a joke that if
if we leave him in attendant for one
hour he would die because he has no
sense of dangers he will cross the
street and will put himself in a
dangerous situation and he's known
verbal so he cannot say anything about
um I mean what how is his feeling things
like that that creates some frustrations
because you cannot express
um but um over the years I mean um
living together and learning how to do
it I think um I put that aside and of
course and his big motivation now the
translational side I really want to to
make sure my science can can help him
and others like him
um to kind of cope with with autism and
daily life and become independent right
um but on the other side I I don't want
to lose him and my interactions with him
otherwise I would be working like 24
hours
um and then just doing that but I I want
to enjoy his life and uh and that comes
a challenge I mean how how you do the
same things that we would do with uh um
we call neurotypical or normal person
right I mean going to a restaurant
um It's Complicated you never know how
this is going to react how long have you
left and sometimes yeah sometimes it
will not last a minute we sit down and
then he start becoming agitated and we
have to leave or or the food arrive and
we have to pack and leave I mean there
are all these uncertainty but but to be
honest I mean makes makes life
unpredictable and I like it I've been
enjoying the process right
um what I would say to other parents or
their families is not let the condition
takes over your life
um but embrace it I mean that that's it
I mean better days will come I'm highly
optimistic about that
um but until that I mean trying to make
the best of your life
yeah it's interesting just hearing you
describe it that way
um Aristotle you know was wrong about
most things in physics but he was right
about almost everything else including
the laws of logic and even philosophy
and and theatrics and so forth but he
speculated on why why is it that
children love their parents more than
sorry why is it that parents love their
children more than children love their
parents and after a long you know kind
of Meandering uh the set of discussions
he basically comes up with the fact that
well parents sacrifice for the child but
it's usually unidirectional it's we
don't expect our kids to sacrifice their
time their effort their money their you
know all their resources for us at least
when we're you know in in kind of age
bracket that you and I are in uh later
on in life we hope that they'll take
care of us as we become more dependent
on them and sort of symmetrical so the
extrapolation that later you know
philosophers and psychologists described
was that well the more you sacrifice the
more you love and in case of parents
with with children with special needs
but also have children that don't have
special needs you say neurotypical I
guess is the right phrase there's almost
more of an attachment to the child that
has the um the the special needs because
you do have to sacrifice so much and it
is so admirable that you have
um not only the dedication that you
obviously do but the the cheerful
attitude and I think that's that's
really touching and I want to ask when
you're um when you first made an
organoid were were you the first to to
kind of think of these ideas and how you
could apply them or you you mentioned
your Mentor uh or like a colleague at
that sock uh was it yeah Rusty Gates
engage yeah that's a cool name made up
of two different uh you know two
different English words uh can you
explain what what is the the Genesis of
the organoid phenomenon was it when did
it start and when did you get the
organoid bug so to speak or were they
coincidence no that that's a great
question and um and again I mean the the
the stem cell history goes goes really
back to to the 70s when people were
were experimenting with brain tissues
even some biopsies and and putting them
in culture and some of these brain
tissues were already in 3D and they were
observing that wow to these um there's
more activity I mean the neurons behave
differently the complexity of the
neurons is much different than what we
are used to see in 2D but that's that's
taken directly from the brain or from
the mouth or from human in in place into
the lab nobody has recreated that from
the beginning I think that's that's the
differentiation
um the first guy who actually did that
um was a another fantastic Japanese
investigator called yoshiki sasai that
was in 2008 that that's when I was
starting my lab and I remember reading
that publication and by the way he
didn't call it the brain organoid or
anything he was just like describing how
he would do it and I said oh my gosh I
mean he can actually create like a fetal
brain tissue that remarkable look like a
fetal brain tissue using stem cells
that's so cool that's what I want to do
it in my lab so I was right in the
beginning but as I mentioned I mean the
protocols were not robust enough I mean
we were trying we're failing
um it was so much easier to get it going
with the traditional two-dimensional
cultures
um that people were like really getting
frustrated
um but then more and more people in the
stem cell field were joining and
realizing how important would be to kind
of uh improve that method and over the
past 10 years we see really
um a a gigantic effort on on recreating
this and make it more reproducible
characterizing them better understanding
the limitations overcoming the
limitations so this is all happening in
the past um 10 years to me a crucial
moment was when we we were optimizing
the cortical protocol to make like a
piece of human cortex in a dish and we
were frustrated because the protocols
include including the protocol from
sasai when we try to record the
electrical activity of those neurons the
activity was quite low very low activity
meaning that there was something missing
in the recipe and and everybody seems
okay with that um because the organizers
were already like providing you with the
structure you could study cell migration
things like that but I was into the
network because that's how the brain
computes right and that's the problem
with autism schizophrenia is not much
about the malformations of the brain but
rather how the connections are formed so
I wanted to get that down so I I asked
like a postdoc of mine to really put
like an effort on optimizing and
starting from scratch looking at the
culture media that we use how many salts
are there and then we realized that
everybody was was using the wrong
osmolarity to grow human neurons so we
fixed that and we're fixing like pieces
by pieces until we had like some very
simple formula where we remove more
things than we we had and it seems to
work beautifully and then I mean they
played that on a multi electric array so
this is uh electrodes that are printed
in a bottom of a dish and you plate your
organ oil on top of it and the
electrodes will capture the electrical
activity and usually as I mentioned we
saw very little activity here and there
and others have tried to do the same
thing with organoid and and didn't see
much as well but then I mean in the
beginning the first week or so we see a
little bit more but not not striking but
as the days were passing we saw that the
electrical activities start to almost
exponentially jumping and I said I can't
believe it this is like a malfunctioned
machine I mean check your electrodes I
mean go back because I mean nobody would
buy this right and this pose dog he was
a clever Julio he's a now A friend of
mine he's saying no no it's real it's
real we reproduced that many times and I
said all right I mean that if that's
real that that would change something
because I mean having a tissue that um
you start to have that level of activity
um and and never seen before was in
precedent uh in in science
um made me think about well maybe we are
recreating the right Connections in the
brain and to show that with we team up
with Brad wojtek
um who is um also a colleague and
faculty here at the cognitive
neurosciences and he showed us how to
evaluate those networks to measure these
brain oscillations which is something
that you can see
um with EEG
um so and then we realized that these
organoids were mimicking these pre-term
development up to post NATO development
so we can actually keep them alive for
several years
um the electrical activity was uh was
growing up for 40 weeks and then Plateau
when they reach about nine months of age
um which is the gestational time for for
humans and is a coincidence or is that
it could be we are still trying to
figure it out if it's just the
coincidence because I my initial
reaction was no this will never happen
because it's a tiny thing the organ wide
has five million neurons a human brain
has 86 billion neurons so these are
orders of magnitude
um but um but then I mean we did it we
use all the controls we eventually
published that and it's right
um so what does it mean it means that uh
the brain can have a kind of a
miniaturized version of itself that can
reproduce itself so it's like a fractal
it says exactly yeah and yeah synapses
are as well all right networking right
otherwise communication is almost
impossible if it doesn't if it relies on
each individual unique personality of
each neuron it probably wouldn't have
survived evolutionarily yeah
um and that brings me to uh to a a
question that you are involved with
Evolution you mentioned neanderthals
earlier today
um uh so I wonder is it true you created
a neanderthal brain you know deep
underground
in your laboratory up there I don't make
make it over to the medical school very
often but uh explain this the
Neanderthal uh mini brain that's
hypothesized to come uh from you just a
quick pause to ask you for a small favor
while my thumb is occupied with old
Albert on it yours is presumably freed
up to leave a thumbs up on this video
really helps me a lot with a good
old-fashioned YouTube algorithm thanks a
lot now back to the video
yeah you know it is um uh there is not
on the end the top brain to create an in
the top brain you need an undertale cell
and and we know that um right now there
is no cells available from the
Neanderthals you can get their bones and
from their bones you can extract their
DNA so going back to that idea that um
um maybe our brains are unique
um because they are different from other
species what we did was to align the
Genome of the Neanderthals with um the
modern humans us and we ask the
following question
um what is unique about us what are the
genetic variants that we only have in no
other species even the Neanderthals have
them and we end up with a list of 61
protein coding genes there are more
variations in the other regions of the
genome but for the protein coding genes
there are only 61. and those genes are
interesting I mean these are genes
related to Bone formation the immune
system but there are a couple of them
related to brain development so
what we decided to do to study the
impact of those specific genetic variant
was to use genome editing technology to
neandertalize the human genome so we did
that in one of the pluripotent stem
cells from neanderthala is involved so
it means that we can use for example a
crispr enzyme or or some genome editing
enzyme to change the DNA from humans
offered me from you and add the sequence
of an Neanderthal inside the cell but
you don't have the brain so in other
words you can isolate that which would
become the brain from the bone DNA and
then use that to forecast or you can see
how similar you can get to a neanderthal
bone DNA or whatever using crispr enzyme
technology that's it that's it yeah yeah
so the DNA I mean should be identical
you know you know your cells right I
mean we take from the Bones from the
Neanderthal there's a sequence over
there which includes the Marine which
includes the nose exactly where the air
should go yeah okay and uh in that
specific Gene the gene is called nova1
it's an interesting name that specific
Gene which is a master regulator of
Downstream a hundreds of other genes
it's different between us and the
Neanderthals so we went to Novo one and
we swapped the modern version of the
gene that we have by the near the Tau
version of the Gene and then from that
pluripotent stem cells then we create a
brain organoid so that brain organoid
will have that protein that is not a
modern human protein but it's an
Neanderthal protein and how it will
down regulate all the other genes that
are supposed to do that and um and it it
did in a very different way and that was
a big surprise because
um even the morphology of the brain
looks slightly different
um we see uh alterations in cell
migration and proliferation but the most
interesting aspect to me is that when we
record the electrical activity of the
neandertalized bring organoid it shows a
maturation much faster than a modern
human so and that that mimics well that
goes well with these um this idea that
uh we are really
um is low developers right I mean
um a baby chimpanzee can outsmart a
human baby right right they are born
they already know how to jump the trees
and then find food our babies requires
attention way more attention so when we
need lies the human brain organoid
the maturation of these networks
resemble much more of the chimpanzee so
most likely I mean you can extrapolate
it this is just speculation and there's
no way to prove that that maybe the
networks of the cortex of the
Neanderthal would mature faster than um
than us so that mutation that we acquire
and it's almost fixed in the human
population
um makes every single brain develop its
law interesting so I wonder
um if you could uh kind of join me on a
speculative uh fictional because we are
you know part of the Arthur C Clarke
center right yeah we got to pay homage
to Sir Arthur uh and I haven't really
formed this question very well in my own
brain but uh but let me let me try it
out on you and we can always edit it out
later if it doesn't make sense
um so there's claims I can't remember
exactly the figure but something like
99.7 similarity between humans and
chimpanzees yeah
um you mentioned neanderthals obviously
and I don't remember which came first
Denise Evans or neanderthals but but the
um the historian and kind of demographer
Yuval Noah Harari has made a case that
homo sapiens emerge Superior because we
had the ability to construct language
and complex uh thoughts and storage and
it wasn't because of our strength
because probably I mean chimpanzees are
probably a lot stronger than us and uh
possibly even denisovans and so forth
were stronger but it was the capability
for language now I wonder you know if we
could maybe ask you to speculate is it
is it sort of a chicken or the egg thing
we don't know which came first the the
brain development the physical capacity
the hardware of the brain or the
software you know to run the language
app to run the you know the history app
Etc the art app
um what what is it what is that missing
point three percent where is it is it
pure Hardware is it pure DNA what do you
think and I don't know it's a
speculative yeah it's most likely a
combination of both right but I I do
think that without the hardware will not
be there or will not be here so it means
that we we need to acquire uh this set
of mutations that would make our brain
susceptible to language to socialization
um much higher than the other species
and I think this is a set of mutations
that we acquire in the DNA that proved
to be
um positive because we are all selected
for that
um over the years so there are many
missing things I mean how these
mutations emerge in the first place it
could be random but how do you fix them
in the population there is probably like
a a strong selective pressure to fix
them and um and and those we don't know
I mean probably for each one of these
mutations we have like a huge history
behind it and it's the same way it's the
same time type of speculation that
people are doing
um on on the other way around for the
sequences of the Neanderthal that we now
have in our genome not the ones that we
don't have but the ones that we have and
um it's becoming clear that there are
sequences that make this Society
susceptible to diabetes covid-19 those
are some of the sequences that we
acquire from the Neanderthals for
probably reasons of adaptation to the
environment
um but there are things for example
um
uh addiction to nicotine seems to coming
from from the name that tells why why
why why why why is that so I mean you
can we can create hypothesis but nobody
knows interesting I'm listening to a
book and uh possibly helping to have the
the author on of a book called The Mind
of a bee uh which is a really
fascinating book so far it's it's one of
the few books that I can listen to with
my kids you know I start listening to a
book it was called salt a history of
salt and I'm like this has got to be
totally you know kosher my kid's gonna
and it's all about sex and like how you
know selling it anyway I don't want to
get into it but this book the mind of
the Beast so far as of you know uh
chapter four is is quite uh quite
remarkably you know G-rated so I love
that uh but one of the cases that they
make or that the author I think his name
is Lars I forget his last name anyway
hopefully I have them on Lars if you're
listening out there uh the the you know
kind of idea that honey was is the most
natural nutrient-rich you know kind of
material with high calories and caloric
work intake that it was actually used by
neanderthals and Denise Evans and
whatever going back to pre-recorded
history uh and their you know cave
paintings and you know where to find it
and so forth uh but he obviously goes
through the famous you know nagelian
exercise of what's it like to be a bat
this case what's it like to be a bee
um but I wonder you know this uh the
caloric in needs of of a neanderthal
versus uh versus a modern day human and
and you mentioned uh things like
diabetes and Parkinson can we someday
Envision taking an organoid which I I
think you might have brought some
organoid uh you know yeah um so I was
hoping I could take that into my lab
down the hall and uh and and start
working on an upgrade I'm due for an
upgrade my Hardware is a little bit out
of date I need I need a new uh new new
hardware not just new software
um can you envision a day when there are
materials there are augmentations not
like neural language I want to discuss
with you later on but you could actually
have a plug-in you know kind of a
upgrade or replacement and augment and
you know even achieve the super
intelligence as past guest Nick Bostrom
has talked about yeah I know that's a
that's a great point I have a mixed
feelings about that
um because there are I mean sometimes I
mean if you if you pay attention nature
gives you ends first
um there are cases of people who are
um who have their brains fused these are
twins people who are who are born with
like the brains fused right
um and there is no evidence that um they
are exceptionally smart right
um so I I I don't think that adding
neurons or or adding things in there
would would make a difference
um but but maybe there are instances
where for example maybe if we learn how
memories are restored and then you can
create
um some kind of
outside the brain to restore specific
memories that you could retrieve with
your thought or take the organoids of a
bee which has these you know Electro you
know thermal sensors and UltraViolet
sensitivity which we don't have and just
you know have that as your package oh
yeah yeah and and by the way that's uh
that's the beauty of the organoid
because you can you can explore those
things um in in a similar way that we
are looking to the Past looking for
genes of Neanderthals things like that
we are also looking to the Future so we
are we are using this genome editing
Technologies to recreate senses in the
brain that we either lost or we never
had
um uh like what and give me an example
um magnetic perception
um we have the genes but they're heavily
mutated so other mammals can can can
probably sense that better than us a
great example I mean that's how they
move around
um but we lost that so a blind person
um in a forest will starve and die right
um so why I mean probably there's a
selective pressure to lose those those
senses but they are there so we can use
like genome editing to reconstruct that
and test if the brain organ oil is now
contains um be cool to see if we can
sense polarized light there are animals
that are very sensitive to polarization
I study the polarization the microwave
background I'm not going to get into
that but yeah to augment the senses not
just to have more is better because uh
it's not exactly as you say clear that
just having more
um I mentioned uh neuralink and I'd love
to get your opinions we've got his uh
you know SpaceX mugs here Elon so don't
don't think we're hating on you uh we we
paid great you know full full retail
price for these
um tell me what are your thoughts about
neurolink and um you know kind of the
the the the the opportunities and maybe
some of the risks of such a such a
technology yeah I and I'll I'll be
honest that I'm not fully immersed on on
what neural link is is doing
um but I have like a vague idea of uh
what what what neuralink and others are
trying to do
um in I think my I mean when I see the
medical side of it I like it for example
can you imagine if those electrodes that
you are implanted there can block
seizures
um my son has uh hundreds of seizures
per day so if I can stop that or or even
himself a bit by by touching himself or
by by thinking could stop the seizures
when it's approaching that would be
fantastic
um uh Rehabilitation this interface um
if you lose a member and a hand or
something and can use like electrodes
implemented in your in your brain to
kind of a move like a robotic arm things
like that that I like it
um
for for normal average person
um trying to mess up with your brain I
worry a little bit
um because I mean there is a reason why
it's so protected probably don't mess up
with the brain
um and but that's my my worry if we if
you find ways to do that um that is
non-invasive even better and I think
these are the discussions that some
people have
um there are some people that prefer to
use eegs to capture the electrical
activity of course I mean in in
Neuroscience it's all about how close to
the action you are I mean the closer you
are to the neurons the better right and
that's why people want to stick
electrodes in there in their actual yeah
yeah but there is a risk associated with
that yeah so former uh UCSD Professor no
uh Stanford Professor Andrew heimerman
who hopefully we'll have on the podcast
at some point
um he uh he has made the point that the
eyes or the retina is really a part of
the brain that's outside of the cranial
vault which you did you know suggest is
that you know kind of the armor that
protects is really vital organ
um would there be work to you know that
seems to be as you say the most
accessible and then um and then perhaps
most medically therapeutic or beneficial
to restore sight or things like that are
there sub-specialties within the work
that you're doing to grow new retinal
cells and again I don't know all the
diseases I know there's you know RP and
all these different
um uh destructive and degenerative
diseases of the eye and the retina is
that a focus focused up unattended of
your research it is it is um uh we are
uh creating like retina uh organoid
um and I do that in collaboration with
another professor here to see SCD and
info Ophthalmology called Walling um so
his lab mix is an expert in in retinas
so use the stems the stem cells from the
same stem cells we create a retina and
we create a Thalamus because between the
retina between the eye and the Brain
there's a Thalamus there and then your
cortex where where the photo reset
actors who actually
send the information
um and and we put those three pieces
together so we have the retina sending
the photoreceptors to the thalamus uh
crossing over the thalamus and now
sending connections to the cortex
that would be so that's the the
interesting part I mean this is um these
are the organ lights how they look like
so you can see that um they're tiny
white balls in there
yeah those aren't bubbles then no we'll
get close-up pictures yeah so when we
make these cortical organoids there is
no uh identity to them they and this is
an interesting concept like blank black
slides I call it the blank blank canvas
right I mean they can be anything yes
um and it's different from from from the
brain that is formed with you I mean
this is without the body right when we
have a brain with the body you're
already receiving contacts from other
regions sensor information that shapes
oh this is a visual cortex this is a
motor cortex and um and as you grow up
those regions become with a higher
identity it's even anatomically you can
distinguish them the morphology the type
of neurons so when we make a cortical
organoid it's an empty canvas there is
nothing there but now we want to plug
the retinum so would they become like
more retina-like
um can we
stimulate visually stimulate the retina
and record from the cortex can we store
memories in there so these are the kind
of questions that that we are we're
making and there are conditions where
um all the pieces are correct and I
forgot I'm blinking the name of the the
condition right now
um but the photo receptors um their
axonal projections are not getting there
for some reason so we plan to study that
condition as well can you describe I
mean is it is it understood the process
by which a memory is formed and by which
it's read out uh I know basic things you
know dopamine is sometimes involved and
strings that involve survival you know
food finding things like that but but
you know how does it actually work at a
computational level do or we do not
understand that we obviously these
neural networks and you know here's a
picture of you know learning it and
training it now it knows a cat versus a
dog but but what's how do you how does
the brain actually read a memory store
it you know it's not a zero or one uh
like a computer chip so how does it
actually store a memory and then how do
we actually retrieve a memory yeah so I
I think the best dinosaur is we don't
know
so that's that's for someone to get The
Nobel Prize okay good no but I think the
uh I mean we all know that this is all
so fast and happens uh so efficiently so
it doesn't seem to be
um uh in in a cell or in a synapses it
could be like phosphorylation of
proteins a process that happens uh much
faster
um if we think that this is all material
related because it mind I mean there are
people who doesn't even believe that
um those process happen in the material
side it may might happen on the
electrical side
um and I haven't seen any good arguments
against or or or for that you still like
really open question but that's exactly
the questions that I want to get with
the organoids because I have the
experimental model in the past where I
mean we have to do it in a mouse but the
right the mouse is very different right
yeah there's a meme on the internet you
know whenever somebody makes a discovery
or something drug or something and it
says just say mouse you know in mice
yeah for us it's you know just say dust
because you know dust is really the the
mouse of the of the astronomical uh
world now speaking of space and things
in the astronomical Kingdom you were
involved with the uh Mission from uh
sponsored in part part by NASA to the
International Space Station now I've had
the the honor and distinction to have on
uh not only in NASA astronaut but a NASA
astronaut alumna of UC San Diego not
only that but while she was on the
International Space Station that's Dr
Jessica Meir who hoping will be the
first woman on the moon uh in the next
five years or less
um so talk about the board's Mission the
brain organoid uh Advanced research
development in space mission what is it
what's your involvement what was the
origin of that particular Mission yeah I
know that's that's another great project
uh and it always starts with
conversation with a good friend of uh of
of mine that is a it's a common friend
here Eric
um and Eric has this interest in his
space and it's always asking me about I
mean what are the consequences of um uh
space or what's the impact of space in
the brain we know from NASA twins
experiments and other experiments that
was done in miles in cells
um that is a space environment either
microgravity or together with a space
radiation
um is not really the the environment
that the brain was made any any cells
human cells are not supposed to be there
um so when you expose yourself that
environment there are consequences some
of these consequences to the astronauts
can be reversible
um others are not
um in in the brains particularly
important because so we've seen in the
animals in in humans as well some
potential cognitive decline so this is a
bad news for Nas and anybody who wants
to do like interplanetary exploration or
or long uh flights um how would you keep
the brain uh protected so that was one
of the questions that we had um uh to to
start working on this project
um well I mean it's hard to analyze the
brain of the astronaut when it comes
back
you cannot make a row in there and look
for the synapses what happened right I
mean it's all um uh post Martin waiting
for the astronaut to die so you can have
access to the tissue
um but it's not going to be real time
um so but an organoid can be a proxy of
the astronaut in the space station and
that was the idea okay let's send brain
we're gonna watch the space station and
let's let's see what happens so that was
um kind of the uh
space colonization idea I mean let's see
what happens to the brain how to
mitigate the process so it would help
NASA would help the astronauts in
parallel there is another thing that
Eric and I were also very interested in
is um what happens to human
neurodevelopment in space
um we read all these science fiction
books talking about people living in
other planets but we never ask ourselves
are we can we cope from the beginning
from the embryogenesis to microgravity
what kind of a human what kind of a
human brain would have
um and and and that was the first
picture that we took from the organized
inside the space station it already
shows that the organoids the way they
were growing was slightly different so
there was perfectly spheres so if you
see the organoids here they're not
perfect I mean they are unperfect right
right but um but over that was amazing
we said oh my gosh they're actually
shaping a ball
um and um so if you if you have a baby
in space maybe their brains will develop
in a in a different shape and we don't
know the consequences of that but uh
probably not not so good so I'll think
twice about having a baby okay yeah it
may be more likely for you than me given
my wife's cut cut us off no more kids
um now the the microgravity environment
of course is unique to a handful of
people and I and I'm curious because you
you know we spoke about the obviously
the relationship and autism and your
personal connection there I understand
you also study another condition called
pit Hopkins syndrome yeah that is you
know reputed to afflict only 500 people
around the world which is you know okay
it's more than the number of astronauts
but but we're talking about low numbers
statistics and I'm just curious what
what drives you to study things like
this where the the you know it's not
going to make you billions and billions
of dollars you're not going to patent
something that's you know gonna make you
uh make you the richest guy on Earth but
um they're not be something else that
drives you to study things there were
other scientists either don't tread
because they might be motivated Like Me
by more venal considerations or or just
the time and the pressure and research
but tell talk a little bit about uh
about what the the interest both in
studying this Hawkins syndrome and also
studying things that would afflict you
know 30 people in the NASA Artemis
program at most yeah yeah no that's a
great question uh I mean from the for
these rare orphan
syndromes or was always attracted to
that because
um the idea is that um they are they are
telling you something I mean all these
syndromes have specific genes that are
mutated or or in affects how the brain
works so by by studying them the mutants
and and in genetics that's what we do we
always study the mutants to understand
the normal so that was the first drive
so let's me understanding all these
genes what are these genes doing so I
can understand how the brain works
um and so that was the main motivation
uh the the board's Mission I mean for
for the astronauts so there is a there
is another motivation behind all of that
which is
um to help uh to treat diseases that are
incurable here on Earth and I'll I'll
give you one example one thing that we
are learning with this uh mission in
space is that
um
a little time
under microgravity when you are back to
Earth your cells age faster yeah so this
is a phenomenon that has been
reproducible in different systems
um and nobody has done in the brain
because we didn't have brain cells in
there but we see that in the organoids
as well so if you can now age the brain
cells I can use this organoid to study
other types of conditions that are not
pediatric or neurodevelopmental
conditions but there are conditions that
happens later in life Alzheimer's
dementia things like that so now
suddenly we have a model that can age
the cells really fast
um by just sending them to space and
come back and I have a model for
Alzheimer's wow so that's where we are
now talk about the um the future of
things like space Tango Cube lab program
and the board's Mission will be another
board's Mission uh and so forth what
what is the future of the space
investigation yeah so um we are very
fortunate here to use SCD because we
receive like a a donation from Danny
Sanford who has been our cheerleader
here for for stem cells and with this
new donation it will allow us to expand
these uh the board project across other
disciplines so now we have colleagues
sending him a topoatic blood stem cells
to his space
um liver cells to space
um and for all kind of a different
projects so we are expanding that and
we're also making
um partnership with um the big players
that might have commercial
um space stations um down the road
Sierra space Axiom space and we continue
to work with the companies that make the
logistics the the hardware for these
cells to to grow like space Tango has
been a partner from from the beginning
so we are uh I think in the the next
year or so
um this program will start really to
slowly expand the expand expand and it
it might become something like really an
institution here at UCD yeah it's such a
remarkable kind of a series of projects
that you're involved with it's it's so
exciting and like Eric it makes me want
to be involved in it but you can only
there's only so much time in a day
uh before we wrap up here and we've
generously agreed to let us uh pry into
your lab and take some footage over
there uh later which will fold in and uh
and kind of a part two of this interview
or maybe maybe uh append it to this
conversation I want to talk about yeah
brain health and in particular as
Pediatrics
um what you know kind of your in terms
of your routine do you have any sorts of
of tips or hacks or things that you do
um to kind of optimize your brain to
prevent neurodegenerative things in the
future potentially obviously these are
you know not this is not medical advice
at this point uh you should not take
medical advice from an astrophysicist
anyway uh but but anyway are there
things that you do personally
supplements are there things that we can
do especially um in particular for those
of us with young children are there
things that are particularly important
yeah yeah I I uh I mean school of
medicine but I I avoid hospitals
so I try to be as healthy as possible
not not to go there
um and um uh I mean I I don't follow any
any specific diet or anything like that
but I try to be conscious of everything
that I do everything that I eat but I
think the most important aspect to me on
my health is physical exercise is to do
to take our time to do at least like one
hour per day or something
um and could be surfing could be running
could be walking but just to keep the
body moving and moving I think that's um
it works for me I mean it keeps me
healthy and I I realize when I travel
too much or when I'm so busy that I'm
kind of uh skipping those days
um that's when I feel miserable so I
need to go back to do some physical
exercise to kind of forget the blood
flushing again and there's been some
some talk I've heard about something
called the glymphatic system which is
like the lymphatic system and processing
lymph and the lymph nodes but supposedly
in the brain you say anything about that
and the role that sleep am I playing
neural degenerative diseases and so
forth yeah so so yeah now this is a
exploding area and have lots of
colleagues who are actually working on
that
um so the brain is really like part of
this interaction with the immune system
is stronger than ever and um the immune
cells in the brain called microglia
um has been neglected for a long time
because I mean we neuroscientists we
like neurons and we forget about the
other cells but there are uh I would say
like a Renaissance of the glia cells
including the cells from the immune
system and we we know how important they
are not only on on maintenance of the
proper function of the brain but shaping
um your your networks especially during
development we're we're seeing that with
the organoid model we are adding these
cell types that they currently don't
have
um to the organoid in observing how it
reacts and um and the differences are
dramatic things that we're never
expecting levels of synapses or or or
the strength of the synapses are much
different after and before you add for
example these immune cells in there so
totally totally important
um yeah
okay so now we've reached the
segment of the interview before we go
sorry and we reached a segment of the
interview before we go into the
laboratory where we go into the
impossible and we want to ask you uh
some existential questions if you're
willing to play along with us Allison so
the first one has to do with your far
future hopefully you reach the
biblically mandated age of 120 years old
I want to ask you what kind of Life
advice or wisdom not monetary or
physical uh accoutrements but what kind
of ethical or or wisdom you know would
you like to bequeath in sort of what we
call an ethical will or Zava in Hebrew
to Future Generations not not just your
biological progeny but but your
ideological progeny your students and so
forth as well what would you like to
convey as wisdom uh when you do depart
at age 120. that's a great question my
hope would be like some kind of
contribution about the brain
understanding and uh and to me it's all
about breaking the doggy month right I
mean in size we start with a strong
Dogma that the brain is formed and does
not change through life right it's
immutable you you were born with certain
neurons those neurons stay with you for
the rest of your life if you lose them
there is no regeneration
um and I think the the experiments that
we're doing with the brain organoid
showed that this is a system that um uh
it's way more plastic more uh
adaptable than than we ever imagined
um and if I can contribute to unlock
that potential I think that that would
be like my legacy that I would like to
to leave
so famous quote from Sir Arthur C Clarke
you're probably familiar with it that
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic and we
always open each interview on the
podcast with Sir Arthur actually saying
that in his own voice thanks to my super
producer Stuart volkow for finding that
somewhere on the internet we also have
uh when when uh Dave the astronaut in
2001 A Space Odyssey says to how to open
the pod bay doors and that's actually
the origin of the word podcast comes
from pod bay doors
2001. anyway
what magical Discovery what's the most
magical thing about what you've
discovered as a scientist and it may not
even have to be your work but what
sufficiently magical technology is
interesting or technology is
indistinguishable from Magic as far as
you've uh encountered yeah uh I would
say uh the first time that we generate
these bring organoids with um electrical
activity on the same level as as the
human brain or the same trajectory I
think that was a Eureka moment and
almost magical because we don't know how
to explain we still don't know how to
explain
um and and it it's kind of the data show
us to us that we were wrong
um and and we couldn't find the
explanation because together with my
colleague scientist I was very skeptical
this is a tiny thing
um you're not controlling it um they are
variable they are I mean really full of
limitations but still they are doing
something that the brain does and I I I
in these days I mean I I'm I joking to
the that because there's so many people
doing organoids you're gonna see we have
like a factory of organoids now and I
always joke with them that they take
these cells they kind of kick start the
process and then they organize they
become by themselves meaning that
everything is genetically pre-programmed
the cells know how to migrate where to
position themselves we don't have to do
that they they do it by themselves and I
I call that a miracle yeah because I
mean how come I mean magic you have like
a stem cell and then you kind of kick
start them to become like the nervous
system and they would do it so it's it's
a miracle it is magical yeah yeah that's
right you know people only look at
Miracles as as things that happened long
ago but in a certain sense every breath
that we take every rainbow we see these
are all miracles witness yeah that we
have this short window of time to share
together and to learn about the magic of
the universe okay third question
penultimate question uh name of this
podcast is Into The Impossible and it
comes from Sir Arthur uh famous uh
statement that the only way of
determining the limits of what is
possible is to go beyond those limits
into the impossible I'm going to use
that as a way to convey advice to your
former self if you could go back and
spend 30 seconds with your 20 year old
self what advice would you give to him
to give you the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible I I think
uh these uh Other Self would just say
keep going
um maybe trying to to be a little bit
more open-minded because I I and this is
true for the scientists especially in
the beginning of your career
um you you care so much about the
opinion of others and if if everybody
says that oh it's impossible that an
organoid whoever reach a level of uh
Consciousness or self-aware well it is
really possible that is well so I mean
if I just believe everybody I will never
do the experiments that I'm doing right
now so absolutely and that brings us to
our final question our final statement
from Arthur who said um when a uh
brilliant but and distinguished elderly
scientist I'm not calling you elderly
says that something is possible they are
most certainly right but when they say
something is impossible they are very
probably wrong so I'll ask you Allison
what have you been wrong about well is
there anything you've been wrong about
you've kind of had second thoughts about
uh that you've changed your mind about
as you've become distinguished though
not yet
I think there are certain uh
circumstances where I could have moved
forward if I would trust myself and
that's that's related to your previous
question on the advice care less about
the other just do what you I mean your
intuition is uh pointing you to do it
um I think for example would have like
better organoid protocols way earlier
than I thought if I would invest my time
because I would think that I would get
there uh earlier earlier and um for
reasons that um social reasons in
science forced me to have like a narrow
minded at the time so I'm learning along
uh as as time passes how to to avoid
that and one thing that I recently
decided to do was kind of a
inspired not inspired but a causality of
the pandemic
um is to go to less meetings less
scientific meetings because when you go
to these meetings I mean you see that
everybody is doing the next step right
and I'm I never thought about doing the
next step I want to do like orders of
magnitude from where I am but when I go
to those things I mean I I see that
everybody's doing like one or three
steps mental increments incremental and
I said wow I mean if I force myself to
be in the incremental group I always
gonna be doing incremental science I
need to step away
um my colleagues might not like that but
um at the end of the day I mean we all
showed incremental stuff that's uh
that's that's important to make a real
impact you need to go the you know order
of magnitude sometimes and I want to
thank you I want to say obrigato did I
say that right go ahead yeah uh for
being on the into the impossible podcast
thank you for sharing so much of your
your spirit and your intellect with the
audience and I know this is going to be
just the light for them as it was for me
we're now signing off associate director
of the Arctic Clark Center for human
imagination Brian Keating and my friend
colleague Professor Allison Moultrie of
UCSD School of Medicine Pediatrics
cellular molecular medicine I think I
got all that right you got it Rockstar
all the way thank you so much thanks
Brian fantastic thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
foreign